better than okay this is a massive test
once again here for the coyotes division
game onepoint back has to find a way kity is out
there now with Michael carcone he's got the puck
in he stores Michael Carone and the coyotes
of the opening minute have a one- nothing
lead depth I don't think you can say carcone is
part of the depth scoring he now leads this coyot
team in goals and that is a goal scorers goal set
up by kerfoot what a pass nobody home for the St
Louis Blues everybody picking flowers everyone
looking at kerfoot nobody picks up carcone most
dangerous guy in this coyotes lineup zooker had
a great look off a feed from Carone I don't think
anyone could have expected that chance here Hayes
and a stop there by Conor Ingram and then there's
Conor Ingram we haven't even talked about him
yet that's the Blue's first shot on net that if
you're a bottom six type of player it was a shot
by to the line dery with a shot and a stop by
olford Alex kerut to
dery now Keller dersy to the
front they score and it's Nick
schaltz picks up the junk on the
power play and it's two nothing
that was no junk watch 15 and red he's going to
get this Puck goes to his back hand between the
legs to Nick smalz on the tape and again Kirkwood
is at it he finds smalz and schaltz doesn't miss
from there that is beautiful Punk movement and
the most disciplined team in the National Hockey
League has allowed another one another turnover
over there and another penalty that should have
been Keller completely had his feet taken out from
underneath him Ty the other way and a stop there
by Ingram yeah I I agree little surprised sha
dery with it dumped in by Liam O'Brien O'Brien and
Kellerman they get buad now out on this unit bad's
got it out High ster across Kess ring looks he
shoots up high oh Kellerman was in front elos has
got size and that time going right to the front of
the net under a minute to go in this period this
time you that out there with that line tracking
It All the Way Conor Ingram that shot coming in
from the right point and now kessle ring with
it Michael kessing drops it melli scores
Matias melli they score early and
they score Late Three cob coyotes
look at the big man on the back hand he finds
CR he finds machell it's usually typically the
other way around look at Krauss fighting that
puck with Krug gets it through and that's a
one te there by machell all in one motion look
at how quick he gets this shot away bom short
side Clayton Keller just bouncing off a hit from
Nick Ley and thrown to the front dumba's got it
try to send it to the net look out malamaki is
back a two onone a shot and Ingram no problem
what a stop by Conor Ingram just in front so a
much better start not so much there for Dumba
as he fans on that Puck and here's the attack
the transition game of the St Lou melli to the
corner Moser K's very patient getting it out of
the zone and melli will skate to Center over the
line Krauss Krauss with a shot rebound fug step
B on it oh what a power move there by Lawson
kuss and Justin F bouncing bodies now the blues
will bring it out trying a two onone here krug's
got it over the line Krug shoots he's stopped by
Ingram just swallows that up nothing to shoot at
a testament to what this team is all about right
there your top scoring defenseman just lays down
not once but twice in front of a shot back out
High chance out of the net Paro robbed by Conor
Ingram use the glass blue lines is going to be
so massive here in this hockey game and we're
going to see a lot of this line I would imagine
C foot behind minut looking to go to work for
zuker with a shot getting a piece was over
oh nice pass once again KET denied there by
valaki sod's got it for St Louis a pinball off
Kellerman sharp angle shot hit the pipe and now
dersy looking to bring it along for carcone Thomas
the other way Ho navit lead pass neighbors is in
Neighbors shoots and a stop Conor Ingram now
Robert Thomas in behind looking to throw to the
front Deni Koli will state it out up on left wing
for schz Tuli to the front k and he's stopped by
Hur oh what a play this hooker will spin it in
behind net elami trying to lock it up carcone
is there again carcone to the front they score
carcone just throws it in front something's up
but look at the work zooker puts that down low
the coyot is forced to turn over Carone just
throws it at the net and goes off the right
skate of zooker not much of a c celebration
there and that might be a kicking motion there
with that right skate yeah and again you can
direct it in with your skate you just can't
have a distinct kicking motion we'll take
a better look here the rights you don't get a
good look there I think the first look was the
the verdict Jean bear Ste that the player
kicked the puck intentionally and then we
got Benders a they're not they're built
a little bit different wants to stand
in front of 100 mph slop shot Wy with
a Shot Pat save Ingram they get it to
the front and they score inside gets
one past Conor Ingram and it's a 3-1
game well you could feel it by the coyotes more
continued pressure by the blues and there's a shot
and for the first time here tonight it was a blue
that got to this loose Puck before the coyotes
sunquist got to it centering feed there to sod and
nobody home melli almost there to get the Stick of
sod but just a little bit Out Of Reach as sod puts
it in the back pretty good rebound control Byers
this one has played to the line big hit along the
boards Matt Dumba but it's turned the other way B
NAIT to the from Dumba breaks it up rebound side
of the net Neighbors in front and it's covered by
Conor Ingram Conor's got it we'll go to the bench
as well kie schtz and Keller right back out for
the coyotes into the Zone kyou backand that's
Steed Away by Ingram and the blues will set
it up cyou out high for Thomas now Kyu for sin in
front they is it in no they say it's in the Blues
are celebrating and hold on trying to get it out
but they can't flipped long sh again towards the
front up the boards to the line great keep crew he
sends it to Kyu side of the net broken up kerfoot
fires it all the way down he scores oh what a shot
into the empty net and kerot is tasted here at the
mullet so good defensively gets this puck just
launches it down the ice and that's more of a
hope shot than anything but he will absolutely
take it his second of the Season Paro back to the
line and out Dumba he'll pull it back what a KN
what a home stand and the coyotes continue to roll